is also worried about being accepted
these people to accept me these people
to accept me and when they don't you die
I'm like a cultural anthropologist man I
just love to just sit and soak up stuff
it's better to create some that other
people criticized and to create nothing
and criticize others hello believed
nation I'm Evan Carmichael my one word
is believe and I believe that
entrepreneurs are going to solve all of
the major problems of the world so to
help you on your journey today we're
going to learn from hip-hop artist
Lecrae and my take on his top ten rules
of success
rule number six is my personal favorite
and I'd love to know which one you guys
like the back and as always guys as
you're watching if you hear something
that really resonates with you please
leave it down in the comments below put
quotes around it so other people can be
inspired and when you write it down it's
much more likely to stick for yourself
as well enjoy
[Music]
just one thing I learned about success
success you know stop comparing us out
to everybody else because that ain't
gonna make you success is not what you
do compared to them it's what you do
compared to what you was made to do so
you got to compete against yourself and
push yourself to the limit stretch that
you need to run toward because you know
that's you know what was you made to do
go do that and don't let anybody be said
you can't do it man just keep pushing
keep going I would tell myself man to
brace yourselves for a real struggle for
real pain for death for loss for you
know hurt and then as an artist I would
I would tell myself you know what I what
I say I put it on the back of the book -
if you live for people's acceptance
you'll die from their rejection and
that's what I would tell people because
tell myself is I was so worried about
being accepted these people to accept me
these people to accept me and when they
don't you die you crumble inside you
devastated but if you already know who
you are like I feel like I'm made in
God's image my Worth and value cannot be
tainted you know you can't add to my
Worth you can't take away from it I was
born with it
and so I don't have to fight for your
approval your acceptance and I want my
younger self to know that be confident
in who God made me to be and be the best
me I could be you know my album would
probably be correlated its anomaly
because I feel like I exist as an
anomaly like nobody knows what to do
with me a lot of times you know
understands like Gospels like wait no
he's what is going on I don't get it in
hip-hop is like wait isn't he you know
so nobody really knows like what what's
happening with to do um but you know yet
and still I'm there's a lane that I'm
running in you know what I mean and it's
just so it's an anomaly so I'm just kind
of like trying to help people understand
like how I can run in the lane that I'm
running in and still be authentically me
without feeling like I have to be this
or that but I'm something different
altogether so you surprised with the
amount of love that you got cause I mean
it's just seven five just to say that
it's a big number one officers right now
it's crazy when it blew my mind yeah I
mean it blows my mind I'm like I don't I
don't get it well you know I'm being
honest I don't get it um I'm just
grateful to do music
just trying to be authentic trying to be
myself be yourself because you know
you're the best you'll ever be in your
terrible somebody else okay you know
trying to hear somebody else even be
found out and it's not going to be you
can't keep that up its act and you can't
keep that act up it's going to train you
so be yourself because somebody's always
going to be willing to invest in you
know something authentic something
straight
anomaly man was really like me saying
I'm an anomaly like I hold a unique
space and I'm not trying to be anything
except myself and I think people just um
just want people to embrace being
Outsiders embrace like you you are the
best shoe they'll ever be you a terrible
somebody else so just run your lane
running up run your race and on and be
who you were maybe being so that's kind
of the theme of the album and then on
you know went on to become a number one
the number one album on billboard which
is amazing won a Grammy which was
amazing and and then I just kind of you
know kept trying to continue to inspire
people with that type of mentality of me
and be yourself you know your wounds
your scars and up you know I got war
wounds and I my sharing over people and
I talk and I talk about it nothing
people grab take it let's just talk
about the reality that even if you're a
positive person is you're spreading
positivity yeah still go through things
or you have temptations you all of that
skill happens like how do you deal with
all that isn't correct uh you know for
me it's a isn't realizing to realize
that I'm not my failures you know I mean
I think a lot of times you look at
yourself you say man I messed up I
failed or you say I am a failure and
that's not true you know those are those
are mistakes you know I like I said my
song you know I count every loss is a
lesson you notice and it's just a lesson
you learn from it and you move forward
so I don't I'll try I don't try to be
perfect I don't try to live my life like
I have it all together I try to walk in
the direction of being perfected I try
to like stay humble stay learning and
stay growing and I keep a lot of people
around me who gonna keep me out of the
nonsense that I probably shouldn't get
myself into and so you know you hang out
with you you you are what you eat you
are who you hang out with you know the
mean and that's really what's worked for
me I think for me man I love
creatively I think I love to just
experience culture I'm like a cultural
anthropologist man I just love to just
sit and soak up stuff so you know you
you mess around and see me with my
headphones on listening to just moraine
day all day long somebody like a lot of
people it's like check out my iPod and
say like what like how why do you have
this like what is what did you get this
from you know what I'm saying and so I
just loved it to just hear new things
that are creatively inspire me and then
in hip-hop is tough because I feel like
it's just been a stagnant place and I
hear a lot of great truths communicated
from the person if our community but you
know me and flamers talking about it but
we just like to see our to stretch
themselves creatively because I don't
think it's as you know hip-hop is not as
just as grimy
underground it does have to be polish
doesn't have to be musical sound anymore
like its Brahman is mature to become a
popular platform for the whole world to
view from you know from Africa to Dogon
Europe and so I think you can't just I
think you do have to think through that
and you do have to be more creative and
so so you know I just wanted to stress
myself in that way
we have a lot of listeners and we have a
lot of people that want to do their own
thing as far as their label is concerned
what made you decide to go out and say
this is what I need to do for myself
because I know this is what the world
needs to hear yeah I think it just came
down to realizing that we have something
unique and sometimes people don't
believe in what you're doing and they
don't want to invest in what you're
doing so you have to invest in yourself
and you have to believe in yourself and
created and push it you know solo and
not worry about you know if someone's
gonna come alongside or support you
because you know what you have is real
and authentic image it and people you
know resonate with it and so that is by
me to just keep pushing and and
everybody that hi I looked up till I
going to see like Diddy you hear all the
stories and how nobody believed in them
and they had to keep working and that's
what happened for us and we just kept
working in you know and and believed in
what we had to you know to offer the
world and it was a secure well
successful negativity in hip-hop you see
a little bit obviously a social media
you see a lot of divisions yeah people
are back and forth at each other and it
always kind of startles me you know
grown man will have problems with each
other alright alright it's kind of like
you're in the hood trying to get out
there to do better for your family your
mother and everybody and you finally do
better but it's almost like you're going
backwards like yeah you're trying to
mess it up for the culture what some of
your thoughts on that well you see
people on social media riffing and beef
in each other's kind of just putting
that negativity of it I paying man you
know it's part of maturity as part of
its just just learning to grow up stop
being crabs in a barrel learn how to
support each other learn how to you know
that's that's just be a real community
because that's how you win is you stand
on each other's shoulders and not tear
each other down all the time and uh and
as it pertains the haters and people
just always who got something negative
to say you know I just say this a little
while ago I said man it's better to
create something that other people
criticized and to create nothing and
criticize others you know I'm saying so
it's like somebody always on something
to say I mean you doing something right
if somebody got something negative to
say about what you got going on that's
okay keep doing your thing because they
spend a lotta energy talking about what
you're doing
not doing something and so I'm like
manage there's just going to be the
reality but just keep it positive keep
it pushing and don't even give him the
time of day so when you look at an
artist like like me right it makes it
was a pastor you know any had a
congregation and he told that
congregation and it was positive then
came back in the wrapping and the wrap
that he's doing is not necessarily
Christian radicular yeah it's very
secular supercircular how do you feel
about things of that nature
um I think mam I'm about being
consistent I'm about you know I'm not
I'm not an advocate like and that's for
anybody it's not just a mace or whoever
it's about you know you don't want to
create confusion like where do you stand
what side of the fence are you playing
here and and just be consistent you know
I think nobody and that's really what
I'm trying to do out in a lot of ways to
show people like listen man you can you
can still hold on to your faith in your
core values and beliefs and make music
that is not necessarily explicitly let's
walk through Jonah
you know what I mean it's right um
without just being like contrary to what
you believe you don't I'm saying so it's
like for me to make a street record
doesn't mean I got to start massaging
eyes and women hey honey
you're in an interesting situation right
now because for a lot of people you're
still a new artist you know you've been
doing this yeah so how does that kind of
like work as be an introduction to
people as you know but still have this
big fan base I'm still I don't mind
people see me as a new Lourdes
you know I mean because they keep you
hungry you keeping on your grind and
keep you humble keep you working hard so
I don't I'm not like yeah a bit here
what you do is you're talking about you
know I'm like a man I'm just grateful
that you know I got a new fan today so
you know just keeps it all in
perspective and and plus it's like
that's when people write for you and you
like care about your fans and you like
you know show them love and you
appreciate them but when you like you
know you send people be arguing with
fans all day long like get off the
internet go make some music
some people write the Umbro they feel
like some wrong with you bro but just as
you financially programming you now
raise another areas up in Brooklyn and I
grew up on government assistance y'all
being I know what that's like over here
was but I've been brewed and being broke
if I Nestle may be rich in character
maybe recent oil so you gotta be rich
and loyalty when you brought us you got
a big statement somebody take you
anywhere you are on room I got your back
polite dog so you know I'll just want to
put it is my dear bro made me wish you
send me out rich in areas the life that
I would be rich in that struggle in try
to make me some maybe one somebody say
being broke made me rich
[Music]
come on say be a pro maybe rich
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this beauty because hard work
dedication attitude so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next check out the link in the
description and go and cast your vote I
also want to give a quick shout out to
Jeff Whaley Jeff thank you so much for
picking up copy of my book your one word
and posting that review on your blog I
really appreciate the support and I'm
glad you enjoyed the read so thank you
guys again for watching I believe in you
I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever your one word is
much love I'll see you soon
see what I mean wrong way
push the tiny fly told me go home they
got wrong change my back but sure it is
not how much he knows how much with no
change
[Applause]
even though how they change you know I'm
more about like you know creating
opportunities you know we built the
studio we got a facility in Atlanta you
know I mean a label we try to hire
people and you know what I'm saying I'm
like trying to create opportunities and
build stuff and you know for me like I
say you know it's all I can't take it
with me when I go so let me invest let
me create legacy let me build something
that's bigger than me beyond me I had a
young homie and he was in the juvenile
detention center in the system for a
while but his brother was a college
student and and and you know I asked him
I said you know the dude who was locked
up I said man why why are you in a
situation you know like the way your
life is he said man because my daddy was
like this is my dad my dad was always on
drugs always in and out of prison so I
asked his brother I said man why you a
college graduate you know you're doing
what you're doing and everything else he
said cuz my daddy was always in and out
of jail and I want to do something
different and so man I just had to look
at my environment in my surroundings I
say do I want to repeat the stuff that
I'm saying or do I want to be something
different than everything that's going
on around me and for me you know I just
got tired of busting my head got tired
of being in low places and making bad
decisions and you know police bring you
home says it's not it wasn't productive
in and you know I'm grateful you know I
had a good grandmother good mother who
just was praying for me and just like
man trying to stay on stay on my head in
a
and I just had a opening transformation
you know it like 19 and I just we gotta
got the wheels turning I said man I'm
not going back you know I mean like I'm
just gonna do something different with
my life and that was it man